[Musique]
on l'a constaté et les autorités
sanitaires le dise la désinformation et
les théories du complot nuisent à la
santé publique mais c'est pas tout ans à
cause aussi du tort et de la détresse
chez les proches de personnes qui
croient dur comme fer à ce genre de
théorie et ça va parfois loin très très
loin
à preuve voici un courriel un témoignage
qui nous a été acheminée mon frère est
assez reclus et se nourrit à tous les
jours de fausses nouvelles
il les partage avec mon père de 90 ans
qui est très dépassé par tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est très dur écrit
cette personne d'argumenter avec mon
frère car il se braque et n'est pas
ouvert aux arguments qui ne vont pas
dans sa ligne de pensée
j'aimerais avoir plus d'outils avoir des
outils pour supporter éditer les
discussions avec mon père qui est très
inquiet c'est pourquoi je m'adresse à
vous merci de votre collaboration
quelle qu'elle soit alors voilà pour ce
courriel merci à cette personne de nous
l'avoir envoyé ce très important et ce
témoignage mais ressemble beaucoup à ce
qui a été vécu par une femme qui nous a
aussi écrit et avec qui on va parler à
l'instant même tout en protégeant son
identité pour ne pas heurter la personne
de son entourage dont elle veut nous
parler
bonjour madame bonjour dans un premier
temps juste pour bien mettre les choses
en place des deux un peu ce qui est
arrivé avec cette personne de votre nom
votre entourage est ce que s'entraîner
comme conséquence pour vous la mana
relation vous avec cette personne et ça
a commencé de façon vraiment un studio
donc il ya plusieurs vies puis à la
découverte des réseaux sociaux
parce qu'au départ je pense que
d'adhérer à ces théories de complot lieu
donné appartenait à une unité qu'ils
connaissent la vérité
mais plus qu elle fait des recherches
sur internet sur ses terres il aucune
argovie pl lui envoie des articles
connexes n'est plus ma part ainsi que la
majorité des gens qui pensent qu une
ampleur démesurée devenu excessif et et
l'afrique devraient chercher à ce niveau
là donc c'est rendu que elle ne veut
plus me parler
à moins que je décide d'adhérer de lire
et de réfléchir sur ces articles pascal
bruckner et beyou
soient sociales ou ses rituels donc
c'est ce qui rend ce moment et là vous
êtes parvenu à aller chercher de l'aide
ailleurs vous êtes allé chercher de
l'aide ailleurs pour savoir un peu
comment ajuster votre votre votre
intervention auprès d'elle non c'est le
triplé j'appelle notre news de santé
mentale lutrin santé social ou
travailleur social de l'hôpital puis
m'ont donné je me suis dit que ça
fonctionnait pas parce que je n'ai pas
dit ce qu'elles soient pas de mal à
autrui et rien à faire donc on les a
personne comme choses mal alimenté ce
s'exclure de la société il ya rien à
voir
donc j'ai écrit au décryptage me suit
l'homme ça suffit je vais la confronter
ses parvenir des articles que je peux
lui envoyer mairie sagement conseiller
en zinc serait pas une bonne idée car
c'était sur le feu et il m'avait référer
à l'organisme et fort le sec je voudrais
des discussions de recherche ont trouvé
pertinent
un concert c'était le premier organisme
tv comme tous les outils pour m'aider
non car entre temps il me donne un
exemple comme une relation amoureuse
reconnaissez quelqu'un qui nourrit une
relation malsaine de cellules sans
comprendre rien de bon là dedans comment
jugez vous parler mais je vous souhaite
bon courage dans cette réflexion
merci d'une part de nous avoir fait de
nous avoir fait parvenir votre
témoignage d'avoir accepté de le
présenter à la caméra bonne chance avec
cette personne et bon courage avec le
gant finement général au nom des
décrypteurs merci beaucoup
[Musique]
bouchra saluons le courage de cette
femme qui a bien voulu nous partager son
expérience de me rajouter à cela
qu'est-ce que quelques conseils oui donc
j'ai demandé conseil à mcroberts d'info
sectes qui est aussi un organisme peut
contacter la dame qu'on a entendu et lui
dit qu'il n'ya pas de solution magique
mais la chose à éviter c'est de
confronter la personne de débattre avec
elles de se moquer d'elle parce que
quand il est question de croyance est
vraiment au niveau émotionnel et si on
confronte la personne qu'on la brusque
elle risque de se replier encore plus
dans ses croyances là il ne plus nous
écouter et s'isoler dit aussi que si on
veut essayer de discuter de ces sujets
là de rester ouverts d'essayer de
comprendre la personne de comprendre
comment elle voit le monde à travers ses
yeux pour essayer de voir de quelle
façon on peut avenir proche leur a
peut-être considérer d'autres façons de
voir les choses et si on voit que c'est
pas possible de discuter de ces théories
la de quand même et c'est de garder un
lien de discuter d'autres sujets qu'ont
en commun avec la personne parce que
plus la personne cisl plus elle risque
de se replier vers ces théories là
tandis que si on garde le lien avec elle
eh bien elles risquent peut-être à la
longue par elle même de voir que ces
théories leur ne tiennent pas debout et
de s'ouvrir à avoir les choses autrement
et accepter d'autres d'autre façon de
voir le monde
[Musique]